je suis chaud là mais la vitesse
[Musique]
magnifique ça va vous nous voyez bien
parce qu'on se posait la question avec
arnaud est ce qu'on dirait ce qu'on est
bien assise fabienne hassiba est ce que
vous connaissez rno vous connaissez
arnaud et déjà vu on a fait plein de
trucs ensemble 1 dont il écoule peuple
coup lui alors parlons aujourd'hui avec
avant en fait un truc est super cool on
a un carton qui est non je vous laisse
deviner aujourd'hui le qui n'ont pas
alors ses soutiens fortement
merci il est costaud alors je vous
explique maintenant à toi que je coupe
et aujourd'hui voilà on va parler ou
jouer au malin noël vieux rien derrière
vous connaissez ça que les s'avoue pas
wen a vite fait ça me parle un petit peu
mais bon ça c'est un contrôleur de
réalité virtuelle causeur c'est ça rien
ne bouge pas vr 118 sél viseur caste web
et les cas ce que dell
on a donc un casque de réalité virtuelle
de dell ip norme arrive elle a gelé ses
super classe nos opérations
chirurgicales
[Musique]
nouveau mot ce truc wahou me stober a
touché la petite odeur de neuf de
plastique
c'est bizarre ce que tu racontes ouais
c'est pas si dur que ça c'est déjà ouais
franchement en quoi c'est je m'attendais
à un truc plus mastoc donc ça c'est le
casque vert ensuite on a les contrôleurs
je ne connais quoi leur provenance est
ce que vous connaissez la marque ktm
s'empilent ils sont magnifiques
ce que je te propose arnaud c'est une
mètres sur la tête devant arnaud et sur
sa voix que rennes enfin vraiment leur
vie c'est la vôtre
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que arnaud
c'est un gamer invétéré parce que moi je
ne suis pas et tu fais quoi certains
coûts pas ce qu'on va faire maintenant
c'est qu'on va tester et on va carrément
changer de décor installé porte
allez bon la transformation n'a changer
carrément endroits on a derrière une
bécane surpuissante ordinateur il part
bosser pour pouvoir faire tourner le
casque de verre on est chez arnaud ça va
bien
cool sauvegarde alors ça fait quelques
jours maintenant qu'on joue surtout
arnaud surtout moi j'ai entendu j'ai
joué franchement si c'est une merveille
alors achats
[Musique]
pour une configuration qui tombe
derrière alors peut-être pas forcément
pas il faut abaisser qui tourne quand
même avoir des cartes graphiques qui
tombe bien après ce qui vous fait re
garçons tous et il faut la hdmi 2 et ça
attention là je les ai mis deux y en a
pas partout et encore moins jsb 3 l'usb3
sa grâce à une technologie kth à ses
nouvelles ouais et des pc avec de l'usb
2 et l'âge des vies 2 ainsi que le
bluetooth aussi pour cinquante et une
manette qui a ses ouvres c'est la
résolution des résolutions on est quoi
1440 1440 au carré voir ça comme ça et
sur deux écrans un pareil en fait il ya
un écran pareil à 1440 par 1440 de
chaque côté et ça s'est pas mal passé
qui fait que ça donne absolument pas la
nausée
alors là moi c'est un peu ma crainte au
début c'est d'écouter un peu nausées
tout ça est en fait non pas de nausées
du tout on se sent bien et on a pas mal
aux yeux tu vois pas moi car seulement
gpu mal aux yeux j'ai trouvé ça alors
que c'est ma première expérience vert tu
sais pas m'en cacher j'ai pas bien trop
con comme ça à regarder demain de recul
un peu parce que dieu ou allah en deçà
va plus de têtes d'hippopotames lemay du
globo est amère après ça est-ce qu'il a
mûri
donc c'est des écrans de 2,89 pouces
franchement si vous font franchement
c'est super parce que la qualité elle
est juste dingue alors on va voir on va
vous montrer après un petit peu au
niveau du détail quand on joue avec
mais la sensation on est quoi ce sens à
la sensation d'immersion jeu pas foule
allez juste top et puis surtout les
petits contrôleur bluetooth chapiteau
m
alors
vous avez ici votre petit jeu eepad on
veut dire joypad après alors suivant les
jeux il ya des situations différentes
en sachant que principalement alors
rejeté les charges et batman qui fait
pour de la vr ils ont sorti non trucs
dessus et en fait ce qui servent aux
consciences a beaucoup ça touche à
l'arrière en fait lagache est ouest qui
sert quand même pas mal
après le pad après pour se déplacer il
ya plusieurs choses en fait c'est vrai
que c'est vachement intuitif le truc pas
là parce qu'on m'a frappée presque à
tout naturellement alors pas du tout
vers là je me mets là je me déplace g
suivre et la folie sur lequel la sur lui
voila voila je défends mon château ils
doivent quand même y arriver ma porte et
dès qu'ils arrivent là je vois bien la
banque de tahiti show fut chaud là il a
mis un casque un peu de télé porte en
fonction des jeux tu peux être sûr des
jeux et si on laisse pas ce que tu as
aussi passer là et tu prédéfinis ton
espace dans ta pièce donc c'est une
configuration à faire sur le casque ou
se balader avec le cas dans sa pièce est
un gros lui paie des murs virtuels tout
simplement et je pense carrément au
doigt la zone de jeu c'est la pauvre et
malade et sensible face avec des choix
les normands du doigt la salle bonne
voie
vision juste de quoi au final le casque
vous le mettez dans votre tête vont
baisser ce clip est là derrière il ya
une petite molette qui sert vraiment à
le régler et à vraiment régler la
netteté et là on a une petite partie
tunise et c'est pour le micro tout
simplement quand un casque avec micro
casque tu branches en micro dessus en
fait ils coulent alors après c'est
pareil
j'ai essayé avec l'article c'est ce
qu'on avait présentée sur une artiste
juriste langue le steelseries en
arctique qui est sans fil donc
effectivement d'un coup on n'est pas
embêtés
ouais cause de casse dessus tu as ton
micro donc ça sera pas forcément pour
des gens comme moi qui ont un casse déjà
où il occupe dans un casque mais par
contre voilà savez que c'est bien y la
connectique après avec le câble
directement relié au pc ce qui est assez
cool c'est le confort parce que là vous
êtes vraiment impliqué hyper ma classe
et courtage ce qui fait qu'au final on
est tenu et on n'a pas un truc ou non
c'est la culture des jeunes ces voix là
parce que c'est bien répartis et en plus
de ça j'ai joué sincèrement deux bonnes
heures d'affilée au moins vingt plus
d'odeurs à côté je vous aime pas mal
d'heures de test et franchement on ne
sent pas quoi ils gênent pas on n'a pas
forcément très chaud dedans et là vous
allez petite ailette votre monnaie bien
ce qu'elle est là ce qui fait que ça
vous bloque ses obscurs si vous n'avez
pas voir la lumière du bas même lalanne
et les mousses c'est hyper d'où le
casque il est franchement bien réussi
par ailleurs tu la trappe et que tu ne
bouges en fait il sent que démarre en
fait il n'ya pas de bouton arrêt marche
dessus maroc et sagna pas donc en fait
il est envoyé directement
il est directement live dès qu'il est
branché dès que l'informatique mentale
ans et l'heure actuelle de reality de
windows tous lance automatiquement son
tour dans une pièce première chose assez
génial quand
donc balade pas d écran énorme au mur
pour des applications enfin bref c'est
génial céline ya encore des contrôleurs
apporté dans les rangs
il faut que ces convois on voit qu'une
main par exemple tu vois qu'une main tu
vois une âme tu vois un vaisseau spatial
c'est ça la prise en main bien sa garde
et je trouve que en plus ils les ont
bien réussi d'un point de vue design
[Musique]
total est déjà fait la belle avant nous
parle jamais ce que je suis et tard j'ai
jamais fait de verser une première
ouais franchement la sensation géniale
je m'attendais à quelque chose de bien
mais pas aussi aboutis et franchement je
regrette pas du tout d'avoir fait une
première expérience sur pc jeudi le
niveau matos ça demande quand même pas
mal de puissance et je pense que son
ordinateur ont fait la différence par
rapport à la cause comme l'attestent ses
regards que c'est quoi une 1070 l'accord
de chez g force c'est pas le plus haut
de gamme mais c'est du très haut de
gamme
donc il ya un bien donc suffisamment de
puissance puissance avec 16 giga de ram
derrière ce jour là aussi avec ma carte
avec ma carte mère plus un processeur
qui tombe bien aussi
certes il un peu obligé expérience pure
dur de jeu c'est quoi cet hôpital puisse
plus pur dur c'est l'immersion et la
sensation de caen a pu tenter non c'est
avec batman ou l'ascension de la
plateforme qui descend on est sur une
plate forme vraiment le cerveau a
vraiment l'impression qu'on descend on
sent vraiment en train de descendre
c'est génial quelle expérience à l'étop
parce qu'au final tu as la qualité en
termes de visuels maintenant pas un bon
casque qui va avec sa tête forcément
plus d'immersion et compte une voie dans
le jeu tu as les contrôleurs qui sont
devant toi d'où tu y es bon expérience
positive très positive
moi franchement je connais le nom de 200
pour rester connecté parce que la verve
je pense qu'on va beaucoup pensent
pareil dans les temps à venir alors il y
aurait de la vère on va parler aussi la
réalité augmentée on va peut-être
pourquoi pas parler de réalité mix pense
qu'à plein de choses ça développe
énormément solution qu'on me propose
d'elle avec un casque de qualité de ouf
1440 par 1440 avec un confort avec une
super 5 rodez contrôleur bluetooth c'est
juste topissime on en parle on
continuera à les garder
voilà les emplois merci a bientot tout
[Musique]